però tutti ragazzi è pervenuto questo lo
video di rocket league io sono pari
genio ci siamo con il buon step per
formare un team incredibile siamo lo
stesso ram 15 match contro gente media
diamond2 quindi speriamo di non
prenderci a nel deretano
ma da cosa volevo fare questa cosa
perché a un certo punto lui ci siamo
parlati e mi ha detto ha subito ma tu
sei giochi a rocket since acquisto
anche io noi facciamo in evidenza e
perdiamo perdiamo perdente ma
chissenefrega tanto noi non siamo
problema giochiamo per divertirci
siamo contro un cane ok va bene è uno a
caso è un gatto è il primo che così non
è vero la bara se non la parola era
veramente un oro fino ad allora però
andava bravissimo che non avete messo
sono stefania l'appunto di nuovo tornato
a casa due volte l'ha fregato fortissimo
e mi ha veramente un ragazzo fortissimo
anche non è però non sono uscita
demolirlo se riesce a portare a lato è
meglio o dio c'è un tizio mi spavento
facile ok e non ho turbo per fare nulla
di quello che vorrei fare ma lo prendo
adesso perfetto non vado non vado non ho
guardato doveri sono stato un babbo devo
guardare dove due fossi della spostata
un po volevo dire la ributta in avanti
perfetto questa è buona se stessa
espugnava bello bello mi piace yes e il
fare bene l'urlo di oggi l'abbiamo fatto
metti solo questo vai vai mai è tua ma
aveva me la madonna come ripartito
questo no accidenti c'ero quasi sì sì
tutto è ripartito troppo velocemente non
me l'aspettavo mai se molto più lento ma
i maledetti massacriamo bravo la para
cento volte
ema è perché non ho tirato forte e
sempre difficile dire forte quando
parlava un po avanti ma cosa sto facendo
dire bene però guarda che non siamo
sfilati nel volo ma quel poco quel poco
lo usiamo per fare per far cosa vuole
veramente standard ma nel punto giusto
al momento giusto e un cocomero in testa
quel cane tanto questo senso ma gianpi
l'ho toccata occhio che collabori
portiere è bravo bravissimo ma no
perfetto no è rimasta lì lo stesso ne
sceglie la schiappa dentro la testa
bravissimo ci siamo da ioan mi piace mi
piace
bravo funziona così bene
vado io ecco la rivista non l'ho toccata
a voi perché cherie aia peccato che
parlano tutte catalano chiude la partita
qua ma non si chiude io sono qua e non
lo turba scaricare tira la bravissima ma
che parlo nello step madonna prova a
prenderla nel muro bellissimo poter
andare meglio sicuramente proprio tutti
gli accessi c'ero meno male perché erano
i partiti non me n'ero accorto bel cross
per lo stesso
io non vado sulla parola che mica vale
dieci secondi ormai è da quante volte
l'ho persa quando ho detto ste cose
ok cosa può andare storto per lo stesso
che può tirare no era gorgo è strasicuro
di servizi è bravo bravo bravo bene non
mi piace il viaggio della fattura sia
protetta male che c'è una specie di
queste sono le altre erano no sono tipo
della ruota panoramica non ha senso
facciamo un'altra let's go for the next
one
la coppia del mondo 7 favi attenzione
allora allora maker avis che poi
concentrico c'è anche lavato al col suo
nome parlo io che sul mio la mia faccia
mamma mia era un sacchetto magico che se
fosse vero vale non è uscita di social
attenzione non se l'aspetta nessuno era
pensato che hai fatto 13 secondi dopo
tanto dato che avevo previsto ha in
realtà te lo avevo rubato per il assorbi
ski la tecnica bravo lo stesso re non
sbaglia
lo strappo nero sbaglia e si poteva da 5
punti i nostri ragazzi top ten t si
arrabbiano
ha quindi prima tanto giovani soldati
hanno perso le boe che goduria quante
cose così tanto
eccola ci sono eccola
basta fare un bellissimo e li facciamo
tiltare perché gli prestiamo di brasile
va beh ci ha regalato ma io un altro al
volo ne farei che questa guerra proprio
tac tac così vediamo che succede
l'ultima ragazzo che abbia vinto di fila
e non possiamo fare questa che fa alla
brutta questa veramente brutta tensione
fra eccolo lì ok ok ok ok ok perfetto
perfetto perfetto e in mezzo bellissimo
che sogno questo ragazzo che sognava
come sognava oggi ma che sogno
come avevamo fatto bene
bellissimo alpino per una volta che mi è
uscito bene lo volevo fare però non
riesce mai ma che fa quello è pazzo
pazzo butta in mezzo ancora e la toccano
lenta lenta lenta e brutta per loro come
la sfrutta il pavia bellissima
ma che belle partite mi fai sognare la
sua fame si si è mai fatti era molto
difficile dire perché non vedevi una
sega vada vada vada vado vado realtà uno
che non abbiamo perso troppo di rimpallo
il primo è vero attenzione perché
proprio tira macchine gravissimo come
chi suona la banana parola para no non
la faranno fare la parata porca vacca
no no no no l'ho vista che stava per
esplodere questi vogliono dire ha tirato
arrabbiato fortissimo no ma ruoto turbo
però vari parti partiti vado su e le
mani bello era bellissima mamma mi era
bellissimo
che sfiga cucinare e di trash disastro
attenzione il favi no non è rimbalzato
che volevo perché lo tira liberamente
ancora niente
occhio non si fa scavalcare sopra vi
lavate la finta aiuto a pronto ad
esplodere
mamma mia mamma mia come ho sudato mamma
mia come s'usava ma tutti questi no sono
state stato registrato dal mio onda nel
cervello che preso che è tutta palo
tutto paolo infatti che aveva preso 62
pali l'ho tenuta libero può tirare
quello da lì
mamma mia è rimasta la tensione potrebbe
sanità ma con terzi a questa partita
proprio la mamma mia ragazza era mente
mi sono cagato addosso però va bene
bello però in partite oggi del file e lo
staff ho tratto un compagno validissimo
attenzione spero che ha visto mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi ringrazio lo stesso né
per avermi accompagnato in questa 22
vedremo nel prossimo video che con
riusciamo a combinare però mi è piaciuto
un sacco
grazie mille di aver visto e milan
al momento mi piace iscrivere a casa
senza vestiti e ha proseguito bella
ragazza
[Musica]